how going BR my name is that HT that
face I don't know what I did but welcome
back to SL what is it come on man slide
over there
slend this is probably going to be the
last slender video I'll ever make
because I don't know it's just the same
thing isn't it I know everyone just
keeps wanting me to play this I didn't
want to play part number two when I play
this and it is just so [__] scary and
just once in a while you just got to put
down your penis and say no you know what
I'm
saying good because I
don't check out this one check out that
[__] it looks like it's moving when I do
this no it doesn't what kind of all
right so I got a lot I read a lot of
comments got a lot of tips on how to
finish this uh game and I will try my
best to actually finish it this time
we'll see leave me alone the tree is not
happy I'm sorry tree I wouldn't want to
be here if I couldn't just ah [__] the
ambient
starts
H I wouldn't be here if it wasn't for
you trees or if I could just climb over
that stupid [__]
fence ah so many questions right now why
who put that fence there how did I get
in here why the
stars
that what was that I swear to God I saw
something in up in the
trees slendy you're so nice I just want
to no no no no no oh oh no no no no no
no no no no no no no no
no no no no no where oh
no no
no
okay he is right [__] behind me let's
go to that
tree sweet ass tree
mother I like them
trees all right let's run I don't care
if it blowers my penis
huh he's gone that
[__] he doesn't even know what he's
doing does he all right what does this
one say no no no no no no no no no
no I like his
um thing
there
okay two out of
eight we can do it Bros
stay strong with me okay I'm here too
you
know I I I'm just so [__] focused I
don't even know how to talk that's a car
it's red you
happy all right so there should be a
note on this and it should be on the
back I'm just holding my penis on this
one no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no I'm backing up let's not
look at him just don't look at him help
me
container oh no
[__] I thought he couldn't kill you that
soon
I was wrong I was
wrong all right one more all right we
are back collect all the
pages I want to sing a song for you
Brothers all
right oh burp and laugh at the same time
girl slendy you're so tender you're so
nice I just want to take you out for
dinner
and then later we can
mix we
love that's pretty good
song
okay that's the giant
penis and we will find a note on you
please let there be a note on you oh no
there's not a note on you is it you're a
little [__] aren't
you ah she's out of
stamina I don't even have a note yet
might as well kill
myself grass I don't trust you I never
what what was the kind of trusted grass
cuz no one suspects the grass you know
no
one the grass will [__] you
up
like I would be scared if I saw him now
because I don't expecting right
now because I haven't even taken a note
yet you thought it was going to say take
a [__] yet I haven't done that
either for
FYI FY Barrel that's a new expression
just made it up just spontaneous like
that every once in a while you just
okay we are not finding anything are we
ah tree you are over there I see a tree
I appreciate what you're doing for this
community tree being like badass in
front of everyone the trees must be
jealous I get it I really do those trees
are
identical that is amazing maybe they are
like a siameses twin tree that would be
pretty cool I always wonder if there is
such a thing you can never know these
days there's note it says no on it but
you know what you just got to stay
positive you can't just keep saying no a
no I
mean okay let's just not look back focus
forward
P focus on the Volvo or a Ford who cares
I don't care that house is kind of nice
I could stay there and wait for Dawn oh
that's kind of creepy too I mean he
would probably try to sneak in his arms
and [__] is he an octopus I'm starting
to think he's an
octopus you know like it doesn't have a
face and a there's no note Here There It
Is grab it run I don't care I don't care
I don't care you're behind me slandy
slandy
slandy slandy slandy
slandy all right we're moving on to the
center
unless we want to go to the car first
yeah let's go for the car
first let me SL you
tonight and I'll make you feel all
right I do
anything [__] I want to be with you let
me
Slender
hi I think the only thing that's not
creepy about this game is a name
cuz it reminds me of
tender that's a good thing in my opinion
hello car how you doing has there ever
been a note on this
one ah [__] you
car maybe we should keep going in
circles and then wait with the house I
don't
know what was that he wasn't even here
is he Invincible oh no I'm in octopuses
[__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__] [__]
[__] F [__] [__] [__] fck did I say
something wrong was it
the don't scare me like that what the
hell he's not even what the hell is he
invisible I don't
want okay okay found a note then we go
to the house what does this one say you
can't run but watch me
[__] watch me watch me watch me running
like a [__] ha he's not even here he
must be lost or some [__] like that all
right I think the house is over
here I have no [__] clue do I this is
not bad news for me that's okay you know
what sometimes in life you get bad news
and sometimes I'm so [__] all right
this
way he's an octopus and he wants to kill
me what did I ever do to octopus
wait P octopusy [__] where're the what
okay H I don't want to look back I know
he's there H nope we're not looking back
oh what is
this an atic Templar thing must
investigate uh all
right that there's a note it's number
four right number four is okay okay
number five is a [__] leave me alone
okay that's fine with me you know what
I'll leave you alone all night
long all right we need to go to the
house right now the house is happening
those are the containers maybe we can go
oh oh I get I'm getting ideas here I'm
getting ideas Bros maybe there's not
maybe oh my God oh my God oh my God my
God okay it's number five number five is
bad no no oh there's a house okay okay
okay okay okay okay gotcha don't shave
your legs all right thank you l oh this
is so bad for me this is so bad for me
I'm running I'm running I'm running I'm
running I'm not looking back because he
is tickling my [__] running out of s
come on run faster run faster oh
he's okay okay okay we are inside let's
find a note and then let's get out of
here because we are inside the house I'm
not sure why I'm singing because there's
a note there's a not all the way to
watching no lies why would you lie about
that why why would you lie that about 6
out of eight I want to go and skate oh
he killed Mr
Chef Miss shine oh no we're trapped
we're trapped
oh
okay
okay okay exit exit exit exit exit exit
exit exit
exit six I got six that was
[Music]
so I'm never going to finish this game
Bros I'm sorry this this was the last
try for me I know everyone keep saying I
play more slander but you know what um
this game became so popular uh I
wouldn't be surprised if the creat made
something new out of this because he
already made one Slender game so that
that would pretty cool um but yeah more
Amisha is coming up I don't know if it's
already up but like you enjoyed subcribe
and I'll see you next episode I me stay
awesome Bros just do it I know you
will activ what the [__]
oh what is going on
what oh f f
f b bounce bom bounce bounce bounce a